let's go to your voicemail 2192 david p
here is i guess i'm going to charitably
call this a suggestion from the audience
take a listen go get the biggest bag of
dicks you can find stuff amor up your
ass yeah okay I mean hey it's advice I
don't know what else I can make a make
of it but clearly someone who wants to
help me out in some way I don't know we
are doing an audience survey david
pakman.com slash surveyed should take
you under 90 seconds to complete and it
would be really useful to us and
figuring out some of the next offerings
of the david pakman show david
pakman.com slash survey i'm going to
tell you on today's bonus show about a
very new ruthless tactic being employed
by anti rhino poaching Rangers in other
words the Rangers seeking to protect
rhinos from poaching are employing a new
tactic some are calling it brilliant
others are calling it way too ruthless
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
also we will talk about the snow
insanity that has been going on here in
Boston and really in a lot of the
Northeast over the last I guess 96 hours
right it's been about four days off and
on of snowy insanity I would say so
there wasn't much this winter maybe like
one small storm but yeah this past week
it's happened three reports all of a
sudden it's not I have some stories I
know Pat has some because of his
experience is getting into the studio
over the last few days so all of those
stories and more on the bonus show how
do you get the bonus show well I have an
answer for you you go to david
pakman.com slash membership and you sign
up you pick a monthly membership you
pick a yearly membership doesn't matter
if the normal prices are too high you
enter the coupon code I voted 17 and
that will give you a huge discount off
of your membership I'm glad for anybody
who wants to use it to enter that and I
will remind you one more time I have
here in front of me both blends of david
pakman show coffee can you hear that
that's the sound of coffee
cool beans that yes indeed thank you so
we have both the espresso blend and the
drip coffee blend the orders have been
flying out on the back the front has the
really cool labels designed by david
pakman show viewer Madeline quirk and
the back has a little bit of information
about the local roaster that we're using
patrick maloney over a blue fire coffee
roasters about 3540 minutes from our
studio in Boston I visited not long ago
we roasted coffee I was able to actually
look and say now is when the coffee is
the way I like it and would like to
offer to our audience and I think it's
an accessible roast it's not super light
and it's not super dark when you went
and visited did you have some funny
apparel on that will have to show on the
show here now I was wearing my normal
coke I thought it would be funny or
visually if when we do like I go and
roast coffee where I wear like a hazmat
suit or because out of it but it's like
you don't really need that to roast
coffee I could just wear normal clothes
you woulda had to buy one I'm here a bit
much it would be a hole to do but anyway
david pakman.com slash gear both copies
available all sorts of david pakman show
apparel we've got hatred mail shirts and
hoodies available it's crazy what's
happening on the online store pad I mean
it's the weekend it's been nuts oh yeah
alright well Pat not quite as excited
about it as I am but hey you know what
he's participating in that that's what
matters this is Backman dot-com slash
membership bonus show coming up next